hello I'm Tom Brokaw NBC News in New
York and I'm sorry I can't be there with
you tonight for I'm a longtime admirer
of Stanley Kramer the director but also
Stanley Kramer a man of courage and
conviction I would like to take just a
moment to talk about judgment at
Nuremburg and why it was not just a
critically important film artistically
but the message that is sent around the
world to a mass of audiences after World
War two I'm an amateur historian when it
comes to world war two and with every
passing year I am reminded of the
lessons that we must keep close to our
hearts and our minds and judgment at
Nuremburg did just that it put on trial
the depth of the mendacity of the Nazi
regime it brought to the bar of justice
the people who were responsible for
unleashing a war across Europe into
Russia with the ultimate goal of getting
all the way to the United States and it
brought to the bar of justice the people
responsible for one of the great great
evils in the history of mankind the
Holocaust that is not a subject that
would come easily to the mind of a
director or a producer or a studio but
that Stanley Kramer did it with such
artistic skill with such conviction was
such a strong cast with such a strong
enduring lesson at the end is a tribute
to him and to the filmmakers who joined
him including maximilian schell who i
understand is there with you tonight